[Music]
with over 75 percent of companies
utilizing more than one cloud Enterprise
IT has been faced with managing
increasingly complex multi cloud
environments a task that has become
costly ineffective and daunting due to
the multiple vendors and tools involved
developers and line of business users
want to rapidly innovate without waiting
for IT to catch up while IT operations
managers need to govern and operate
workloads across multiple clouds easily
and efficiently with IBM cloud
automation manager developers and line
of business users can accelerate
innovation with rapid provisioning of
complex multi cloud workloads instant
access to pre-built automation packs and
self-service access to preferred cloud
and app environments using IBM cloud
automation manager IT operations
managers looking to optimize cost and
control across clouds can easily govern
deliver and optimize multi cloud
environments and integrate with adjacent
capabilities and applications IBM cloud
automation manager multi cloud
management with cognitive insight your
clouds your applications your enterprise
get started on bluemix today